so the girlfriend 19th you plan to go
the film festival route yeah what are
your thoughts on that and why choose
that route when there's some debate on
yeah going back to my comment as to I
believe aspiring filmmakers your first
and quite quite often your only goal
ought to be completion just the success
of making of them honestly that was my
goal for girlfriend NT I could have
spent a year to write the script and
making it a lot better I didn't I wrote
in like a few months we pre produced it
in a few months so that being said I'm
not exactly sure how marketable this
film is I I don't know how much money I
could earn so my primary goal not even
secondary not even third goal of the
film is not to make money it's more of a
professional career type thing a
networking type thing meaning people
through it getting into an interesting
dialogue through and conversations
through it and I believe that would
happen more so in the film festival
crowd the film festival circuit versus
putting it online trying to sell it on
Amazon or whatever you know so that's
why I've chosen to take the festival
route with it and quite frankly I as a
filmmaker I've never attended really
solid healthy festivals I would love to
experience that I'd love to be part of
that I'd love to make those connections
and third I didn't go to film school and
I've heard film vessels are are just
really good in terms of meeting
collaborators meaning folks to team up
with and work with so i would love to
just attend philip Ezard as a film maker
and me potentially future collaborators
and team members we have a conversation
today
filmmaker Pablo pappano his film is
clicking for love and he had some great
early success in terms of the film
festival circuit he submitted he said
all together you submitted to 80 film
festivals he got he got in the 13 the
hostels Mike but I believe one of the
early ones that got hooked on that I'm
not sure it goes the premiere it was
crazy but he got he got in in temecula
years old junky d ok that's a lot of
money yeah love you could make another
film ok hehe gotten god bless you got it
let's imagine what he said there um it
was it was an enthusiastic response he
said you know here you have a solid just
a wonderful film festival growing
audience you know great crowds as people
were excited to see the films and that's
what you're looking for we have absorbed
it exactly that he said after he even
after that one this next teardown is he
started to apply and get into some of
those festivals it really bottomed out
yeah you know he traveled to all these
film festivals there was no promotion
you know people wouldn't come out and
literally you're sitting in an audience
with just other filmmakers there's no
other audience except for other
filmmakers and he didn't get as much
value he out of that experience so how
do you how do you react like kind of
knowing that now how far do you really
want because you're saying yeah exactly
you're saying you want that experience I
thought it's going to quickly jump wrong
ya know how do you respond ok my
response is I don't know what to say
because first of all grow for 19 I've
only submitted tonight ok and those were
nine top springtime festivals I I went
for broke so and I was told by certain
folks that i may just be able to squeak
the movie into those festivals i'm away
no sunday at South by Southwest but I
didn't get it to anyone actually I'm
waiting to hear back from
that's not true from what I'm going to
answer that indirectly I have I spent a
lot of time researching festivals for
girlfriend 19 I walked away having lost
a lot of hair probably it was one of the
most frustrating experiences in my
filmmaking career as a consumer for
products it's become so simple now
amazon reviews cnet reviews and all
these dudes right festivals as far as I
know it just doesn't exist there is very
little accountability there's a very
little communication about festivals in
a structured centralized banner so what
ends up happening is a lot of people a
lot of filmmakers who most of them have
like a zero money and sending their film
to festivals scattershot blindly
ignorantly and that is not only a
tremendous waste of money but that is a
major waste of emotions and hope and
faith which is even more valuable than
money you know so I wish I wish I don't
have the time to do this but I wish
someone someplace you know Peter yeah
there's books Chris score and all that
but it's not really it's not really you
know holding festivals to a standard you
know like like like Amazon reviewers do
or seen it or these other folks do / for
goods and products I wish there was
something to direct us indie filmmakers
and submitting our films the only thing
I could think of is here in LA there's a
man named
Ethan Harris he does a film festival
seminar he does that about twice a year
at the egyptian theater and that's like
the only thing i can think of but you
know it's not on video it's not online
fact I know Percy I'm gonna dull maybe
we should record the next one throw it
online and you know maybe you could pay
a certain feed to watch it but that's
what I'm saying it's it's very
frustrating I felt so frustrated and it
to make matters even worse with this
whole lack of accountability lack of
standards or whatevers to make it even
worse festivals and rightly so they're
subjective you know like it's just a
group of people with their own biases
with their own tastes saying yeah ok nan
yeah yeah so even if you do your
research even if you do your due
diligence you end up with a subjective
you know a panel of group of people so
it's very very frustrating I die I wish
there was more help out there for us
indie filmmakers but that being said
you're still going to go that route have
you given yourself a cap and you say i'm
only one of these few festivals this is
how much i'm spending and after that i'm
walking away yeah so this is what i did
i went for the top i went for broke one
of my biggest regrets in life believe it
or not is i did not apply to more
prestigious colleges because i close the
door on myself i looked at my GPA and my
own insecurities and i said i'm not
going to get into Berkeley you know I'm
not going to get into Stanford so I
didn't even apply with girlfriend idea I
don't make them i think i went for broke
and i'm happy even though the doors were
closed I'm still happy I gave myself a
chance number one now we're talking
arguably the top ten festivals in
in the country so i did that number two
what i did was i had couple friends who
have a lot of festival experience they
had films in pretty prominent festivals
watch my film and say based on their
experience which festivals do they think
I have a shot at so that's a pretty
well-informed thing to do you know again
diminishing the randomness element you
know and then again another plug for
Thomas Thomas Ethan Harris who does the
film festival seminars he's up for hire
you could hire him to watch her film do
a film festival consultation and he'll
give you a list of festivals this by the
way he's the co-founder of the LA Film
Festival and he's just he seemed like
14,000 first-time feature films or some
crazy like that so I hired him and for
it's a very reasonable rate and he gave
me a list so now chipping away at that
list and it's about like ten festivals
that's it I'm not going to do any more
than 20 total or 19 total that's it
you